hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast cannabis testing making
life easier in the laboratory
presented by Kathy shunderson a
principal scientist and workflow
development at Mill for Sigma the life
science business of Merck KGaA and
darmstadt germany i am kelly baka
blogger and I will be your moderator for
today's events we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries Labradoodle a
defiant if ik social networking website
and producer of educational virtual
events and webinars before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type in your
question and hit Send well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Cathy Stetson I will now turn the
presentation over to her
thank you very much Kaylee and thank you
everyone for logging in to watch this
today what I'm going to be talking about
are some approaches for those of you
that are interested or maybe you're
already doing testing of cannabis in an
analytical laboratory some of the
approaches that we've found to help some
of the pain points for some some of the
tests that are done so we're going to
cover I'll start with pesticide testing
which is a required test in many states
in which medical and recreational
cannabis is legal then I'll talk a
little bit about potency testing a
couple of new approaches for doing
residual solvent and testing for
terpenes and finally all my I'll wrap up
with mycotoxins so doing pesticide
testing on flower material you start
basically with a beautiful bud and you
have to go through a series of
manipulations in the laboratory to get
an extract that you can inject into your
analytical instrument and in the case of
pesticides many of the required
pesticides that laboratories have to
test for require the use of both GC and
LC mass spec to be able to cover the
entire list also to some of the issues
when doing this type of test the
extracts can be very very messy as you
can see from the picture in the upper
right hand corner they can be green they
can have other things and then they
interfere with detecting the pesticides
of interest so that's an issue is being
able to clean that extract so it can be
injected in the instrument also in the
case of doing lcms these these extracts
are in organic solvent so injecting that
directly into an LC ms depending on your
starting mobile phase conditions the
peak shapes of the first few Peaks can
be very poor and I'm going to show you a
way to address that so let's start with
the extraction many labs when they
extract pesticide residues from cannabis
use an approach called koechers and that
is an acronym which stands for quick
easy cheap effective rugged and safe it
was originally developed for doing
pesticide residues out of fruits and
vegetables it's a very simple technique
doesn't require much equipment it simply
uses loose salts and sorbents organic
solvent and a centrifuge and a 2
assaults what they do is sample is
homogenized is put in the tube then an
organic solvent usually a cedar nitrile
is added and the sample is shaken to
extract the pesticides at that point
then salts are added and what these
salts do is they cause any water in the
sample to separate from the organic
solvent and the pesticides will be in
the organic solvent part then the
organic part is taken off put into
another tube with loose sorbents that
act as a clean up so once again the
sample is shaken and any the unwanted
background sticks to the loose sorbents
there are two official methods that
describe this technique in one is in the
AO AC and the other is a European method
as I know listed on the right hand side
of the slide so as far as the salt go
what kind of salts are used well there
are different salts depending on what it
is you want to do it when the technique
was first developed they started out by
just using sodium chloride and magnesium
sulfate and then as the technique became
more sophisticated and applied to more
and more pesticides they started coming
out with different salt combinations to
offer in buffer capacity and once again
the salt act as partitioning agents and
they optimized the extraction efficiency
so they also help to drive the
pesticides into that organic layer now
as far as the cleanup goes the cleanup
sorbents which are loose also there's
three very common ones that are used and
available and for multiple vendors PSA
which stands for primary secondary
amines and this takes out things that
will interact with the main group so
fatty acids organic acids polar pigments
sugars things like that carbon which
takes out coloured interferences mainly
chlorophyll and carotenoids and c18
which by hydrophobic interaction will
take out fatty background
these are very common sorbents now
there's a new class of sorbents made
with zirconia and they're available for
milk or Sigma called Z sub sorbents and
these have some unique characteristics
they remove lipids pigments and they can
be combined with other sorbents to
provide even a wider array of clean up
so these tops
well actually the bar should go down to
the C 18 but these top three sorbents
they're described in the official
methods the AO AC and the European
methods for doing this catchers
extraction clean up and as I said before
the Z sub sorbents are unique so they're
a new type of sorban that can be used
for this catcher's cleanup and remember
that the role of the sorbents is to trap
the interferences that Co extract with
the analytes that come out in the heceta
actual layer with the analytes but at
the same time we do not want those
sorbents to remove our target analytes
which are the pesticides so let's talk
about that for a minute
okay so when using a conventional
mixture that is very common in catchers
PSA C 18 and carbon which we show in the
graph is PSAC 18 NB carb that's our
version of carbon what's shown here is
recovery of pesticides that were spiked
in a cannabis and then extracted back
out with the cleanup and after the
cleanup the recovery of the pesticides
using this PSA C 18 nd carb mix are
shown by the purple bars on the chart
and most of them are not bad okay there
are above 80 percent 70 percent which is
considered acceptable for this type of
application but there is a problem with
one this cannot see fin here now there
is an alternative mix that can be used
for doing a cleanup and catchers and
it's called Tupou q verde to mix
available for us and it utilizes one of
these zirconia sorbents
to help trap interferences as far as
recovery goes
after cleanup the Verde offers some
advantage over all it offers higher
recovery 75% vs. 71 and as far as
reproducibility it's very very
comparable to using the conventional mix
its main advantage though is that it
will not reduce the recovery of
compounds that would stick to a carbon
the env carb that's in the conventional
mix and cannot see fin which is the
structure is shown here the structure
cannot see fin is planar okay so it will
stick to these graphic ties carbons
quite strongly
now the verde mix has a specialty carbon
in it that is not as retentive for these
planar molecules so hence we get a much
better recovery of this Kanak sieve and
pesticide using the verde mix compared
to the conventional mix so move into the
LC side of things and I mentioned that
the pesticides have to be run by both GC
and LC because you can't do all of them
by one technique or the other very well
okay so the catchers extracts are in
organic solvent and the LC method start
out with a high a lot of times their
gradient methods and they start out with
high aqueous to get pesticides to retain
on the column so there's a couple issues
with that first of all when injecting an
organic solvent into this make sure your
early loading Peaks tend not look very
nice they're kind of ugly the kind of
broad another thing is that during that
cachers extraction in addition to those
pigments and those lipids and things and
sugars that can come out with the along
with the pesticides in the extraction
cannabinoids come out too so obviously
you're doing cannabis you're going to
have cannabinoids they're going to Co
extract with the pesticides and the
levels are quite high so these
cannabinoids will not be removed
entirely by any cleanup
unfortunately so what happens is is when
you inject them into an instrument they
end up going into the detector now with
GC it's not as much of an issue because
they go through the column then they go
through the Tector and then they go out
to waste but now see they can go into
the detector and they can get the
detector quite dirty that requires that
you take it apart more frequently and
clean it
so one approach for doing that would be
to try to adjust your chromatography so
that the cannabinoids that are still
left in that extract with the pesticides
will elute later on the column or after
the pesticides the idea being is after
your last pesticide goes into the
detector if you have a valving system
between the detector and the column you
can switch it to waste so the
cannabinoids can then dump to waste and
that's what we investigated here now
most people when they're doing HPLC they
reach for a c18 column this is very very
common okay
and what we did here was we show a
comparison between a typical pesticide
run and these pesticides many of them
are on the list required by the state of
Oregon and we've overlaid them with the
same run conditions with the major
cannabinoids that are present in
cannabis and you can see that they in
red that's where the cannabinoids are
they elude pretty much in the middle of
the pesticide so there's no way you're
going to be able to do that dump step
that I talked about because if you try
to dump the cannabinoids to waste you're
going to dump some of your pesticides
too but if you choose a different column
and in this case we did the same
experiment but with a column called the
RP amat we found that the pesticides
were alluded a little bit earlier
relative to the major cannabinoid so in
that case we could possibly take
advantage of a dump step to dump those
cannabinoids to waste and we can still
use the amat to analyze or pesticides so
once again can I have a noise or Co
extractor with the pesticides they can
contaminate the lc-ms so what we're
doing here is trying to elute them later
than the pesticides so we can dump them
to waste now in addition to column
choice the gradient that is used can
also help using in this experiment what
we did was we compared using acid or
nitrile in our gradient to methanol to
see if we could get the cannabinoids and
the pesticides to allude even further
apart so the top chromatogram we're
using a methanol gradient and the black
is the pesticides and the red is a
cannabinoids now on the bottom we're
using a cedar natural gradient the black
is a pesticide the red of the
cannabinoids and we found them to
a little bit better separation between
the cannabinoids and the pesticides when
using a cedar nitrile
so combining an a mid column with an
Ysidro nitrile gradient gave us the best
separation of all so we were able to to
use a dump step to dump the major
cannabinoids to waste before they enter
the detector and not lose our analytes
of interest so now on to the second
issue when injecting these extracts into
lc-ms systems especially when you're
using a gradient starting with a high
organic you're injecting I'm sorry a
high amount of aqueous in the mobile
phase you're ejecting organic into it
what can happen early alluding Peaks
will tend to broaden out because you
have solvent mismatch with the mobile
phase and that's what's happening up
here with our a mid column the first
hamon column that we looked at was an
amen' column cup that was made from a
particle called a fused core and this
particle has a solid Center and a porous
shell and the idea behind it is that
it's a very highly efficient particle so
that you can run separations highly
efficiently but faster okay so that's a
the best way to go if you can but what
we found was when we switch to a and a
mid made from a fully porous particle
that's one that does not have that solid
core we got a little bit better peak
shape most likely due to the fact that
the fully porous particle could
accommodate this slug of organic a
little bit better and also we got better
mixing now by attaching a guard column
to the front of that fully porous column
we improve the peak shape even more so
we are still able to inject that organic
slug into the starting mobile phase
conditions and get halfway decent peak
shapes for our early eluding Peaks what
some labs will do to deal with this ugly
peak shape tissue is they'll take their
country's extract and dilute it into
aqueous so that they can inject it and
get decent peak shapes but if you dilute
your your sample your of course you're
going to raise your reporting limits so
then also create an extra step in your
workflow so by just using a fully porous
column with a guard you're creating a
little extra mixing and improving your
peak shapes of the earlier looters and
using a guard column is a really good
idea anyway when you're running these
really messy extracts it's going to
increase the life of your more expensive
analytical column
so putting all this together using our a
mid column with an acetal nitrile grace
based gradient a fully porous particle
structure in the amick column and a
guard these were the results we got when
we were looking at cannabis that was
spiked with pesticides what the tea I
see on the top shows is the pesticide
Ellucian pattern pirated in with our
last diluting pesticide came off at
thirteen point three minutes and the
chromatogram right below it I pulled out
the iron the major iron for cannabidiol
and THC two major cannabinoids that you
see in cannabis to show where they elute
relative to the last pesticide and you
can see that they come off after and for
other major cannabinoids that are
present in cannabis too on the a mid
column we know that they come off even
later than THC so you should be able to
dump those to waste as well so what
about the GC side of things because I
mentioned you have to run those extracts
by L C and GC well in GC a couple of the
interfering classes of compounds are
terpenes and cannabinoids unfortunately
nothing is going to preferentially
retain terpenes you just have to deal
with that maybe choose the right ions to
look at if you're doing ms/ms which you
probably are the right transitions to
look at where you don't get interference
as for the co extracted cannabinoids
they do come through the column and
Appel cure verde mixture will reduce
these a bit the acidic ones specifically
so we do find that we get a total area
counts at looking at background we do
get a slight reduction over using a
conventional mixture 35% reduction in
background verses 31
so just staying on GC for a minute
maintenance is really important
especially when you're doing these types
of samples because repeat injections of
a green extract even after cleanup it's
like rain but it's still a little green
can at you can end up with contamination
in your liner and I show a couple
examples of different GC liners with
residues in them after you know 1020
injections sometimes you'll get these
residues and these residues create
active sites where pesticides can end up
degrading and absorbing and so that your
responses will be reduced also if you
have a seal at the bottom of your inlet
that can get dirty too and that's what I
show here is a brand new seal which is
nice gold color compared to to other
ones above it the one on the right has
been exposed to injection of of
agricultural samples extracted by
catchers and the one on the left is just
from just H so these need to be replaced
and periodically so moving from
pesticides into potency testing this is
probably the number one test that is
done because we need to know what the
content of the major cannabinoids are in
the products that we're selling to
consumers quantitative analysis
extremely important processing can
affect cannabinoid content and
consistency especially for extracts
because many times when the extracts are
made from concentrates that has gone
through some kind of process to convert
all the acidic forms into neutral and in
the cate case of THC priority node is
the neutral form is the format
psychoactives I should say psychotropic
now here in this application what we did
was we looked at a couple different
forms of edibles gummy bears and
brownies and we used a very simple
catchers like extraction followed by UV
analysis for looking at these HPLC UV
okay so we used HPLC for our analysis so
why not GC what's the difference anyway
let's take a look at a GCMs analysis of
THC nice peak to pretension time of
twenty two point seven minutes and
that's the mass spectra of it now let's
take a look at a GCMs analysis of the
acidic form nice peak similar retention
time that's interesting and similar mass
spectrum okay so what happened here well
it's pretty well known that acidic
cannabinoids can be converted to neutral
cannabinoids by eating them they
decarboxylate and in the case of THC
that's essentially what happened here it
decarboxylated when we injected it into
the GC because the injection port is hot
and what we're detecting is the neutral
form so if you're trying to do a sample
that had both the acidic and neutral
forms in there you couldn't distinguish
them they would just elute as one peak
as the neutral form HPLC on the other
hand can distinguish them there's no
heat involved so what I'm showing here
are Delton 8 + Delta 9 THC the neutral
forms and then the acidic form so
they're very well they're distinct Peaks
well resolved so that's why HPLC is the
method of choice for analyzing for
potency now these edibles that we took a
look at the first one was brownie and we
looked at chocolate brownie with with
frosting and for the extraction we did a
very simple catchers like extraction so
similar to what we did with the flower
material when we're looking at
pesticides so we weighed brownie
put it into a tube added a seeder
nitrile to it and shook it up and then
added salt shook it and centrifuged it
and there was a some fad that came out
of the brownie along with the
cannabinoids that we were looking for it
co extracted out so to do the cleanup
we put the organic layer in the
refrigerator for a few hours and the
fats just precipitated out it was pretty
simple and it took a few hours but you
could go off and do something else
during that time and then took that
extract and analyte to by HPLC and for
the spike level that we spiked at which
was 40 ppm micrograms per gram the
recoveries were pretty good they're all
above 80 percent and our reproducibility
for spikes replicates was was very good
with our C's below 5
you
now for doing
and testing and terpene testing you
could use headspace for residual
solvents and a lot of labs do a solvent
extraction followed by GC for terpenes
so that's two different approaches two
different sets of equipment or a new
approach would be to use a technique
called solid phase microextraction or
for short SPME and you could use that
technique for both now what is SPM a if
you're not familiar with it that's a
whole nother course but I can just
briefly tell you how it works it
essentially is a micro extraction device
and it consists of a fiber or coated
fiber which is shown the center picture
there and that coated fiber is exposed
to samples a lot of times it's used for
headspace sampling but it can also be
immersed in aqueous based sample and
these analytes then will be extracted by
the fiber the fiber that is taken out of
sample brought over to a GC and put into
the injection port and desorb directly
by the heat of the objection port so
this illustration explains the steps
that are involved with doing an
extraction in the first step you would
here you put your sample first of all in
a file that had some kind of septum cap
the SPME device and what's shown here is
a manual device so the actual fiber that
does extracting is inside of the little
needle that sticking down from the
holder we call that the needle assembly
so you use that needle assembly to
puncture the septum in the sample then
there is a plunger on the top of the
holder that you depress and that exposes
the fiber inside of the sample after the
extraction is complete you bring the
fiber back up inside that needle
assembly then take the whole thing out
of the sample take it over to the GC and
reverse the process and expose the fiber
when you're inside the GC Inlet and by
thermal energy the analytes are desorbed
off they go onto the GC column and you
just do your analysis just like normal
the advantage of SPM is there's no
solvent at all its solvent less so you
don't have any organic waste and also
the fiber is reusable so unlike a solid
phase extraction we use the device once
and throw it away you can use this
device over and
and over again and what I've shown here
is how it's being used manually
it can also be automated very very
easily there's there's other vendors out
there that make Auto samplers that can
accommodate spme and I'm just showing
the one that we have in our lab that it
has a magnetized head on it so it can
pick up the sample move it over to a
heated agitator put it in the agitator
and it can actually do the sampling and
what's shown here is it's actually
inserting the SPME fiber assembly down
into a sample and then it pushes down on
the plunger and exposes the fiber and
then after it's done it goes over and
goes into the injunction port of the GC
and desorbs so you can just set the
samples up and walk away it's really
very nice and these are called Xyz Auto
samplers and they can also be used for
other things too liquid injection and
other things too so they're
multi-purpose and it could be used for
spme so I used spme first to look at
residual solvent and since I am in the
state of Pennsylvania medical cannabis
was just made legal recently and we
don't have access to concentrates and
whatnot and at the time that I did this
work I used hemp extract and I spiked it
with a list of residual solvents that
were of interest to those that are doing
this type of testing and I extracted it
by spme and then quantitated it against
a curve that I prepared in soybean oil
and extracted by spme now why did I
prepare a curve in soybean oil I have to
explain one thing about SPME that
sometimes is people don't really
understand off the bat but unlike spe
solid-phase extraction which is an
exhaustive extraction spme is what we
call an equilibrium extraction so it
doesn't extract everything out of the
sample so therefore you do an extracted
curve in order to quantitate samples not
a big deal especially if you have
automation you just set up the curve and
you run it and then you run your samples
afterwards and that's what I did here I
made up a curve in soybean oil and then
ran my my hemp oil right after that but
I spiked and I also ran some hemp oil on
spiked now you'll probably notice that
butane and isobutane aren't on my list
and I know that those are common
solvents that are looked for for labs
doing this type of testing and the only
reason is
they would work just fine by the method
I'm going to show you but I just didn't
have the right kind of setup to spike
those gasses into them into my materials
accurately the column that I chose is a
porous layer open tubular column capella
to plot and I chose it because if you do
use butane and isobutane this column
will retain them and separate them from
all the other analytes of interest and I
use GCMs in full scan mode ok so these
are my calibration curves out of my
soybean oil and I got pretty good
linearity as you can see here I was
actually getting such good sensitivity
with this method that at about 70 ppm I
was starting to see a little bit of
overload on some of the compounds and
the cutoff I know for organ it varies
depending on the psalm you're looking
for but generally if you can see down to
10 ppm that's going to be fine for most
of these which spme has no problem with
it's an enrichment technique very very
sensitive so in my spike 10 boil I
spiked it at 10 ppm and for spiked
replicates my recoveries we're above 80%
for all the compounds and my RS DS were
very good I got very good
reproducibility they were below 10% now
hexane is missing missing from my bar
chart here that is because I detected
hexane in my unspeak temp extract at 59
parts per million so obviously I know
what they use to make that extract with
okay terpenes now this technique
solid-phase microextraction SPME can
also be used for doing terpenes either
qualitative profiling or quantitative
analysis now in this application here we
have some cannabis that we have obtained
through ni da and we did a tour peen
profile on the material just on dry
flower material by exposing n SPME fiber
to the headspace
there's different types of SPME fibers
available just the one that you select
depends on what you want to do so I
chose one that would be very good for
getting a low molecular weight and very
volatile compounds so I chose the one
that's described here this DVB car box
in PDMS
with a very very simple extraction I
just exposed the fiber to the headspace
over the dry plant material for 20
minutes after I had warm the sample up
for 30 minutes to get it equilibrate and
I was able to identify 45 different
proteins in that plant material now I
did that using a combination of GCMs and
retention indices also to SPME can be
used in a field sampling mode and these
samplers can be taken out in the field
they're available in little sealed
holder so you do your sampling in the
field and when you bring the fiber back
inside of the assembly it it's sealed
off with a septum and then they can be
shipped back to the lab and analyze and
so we did a something called a cannabis
boot camp out in Portland Oregon a
couple years ago at chalice farms which
is a dispensary there and we use these
spme field samplers to look at terpene
profiles from three different varieties
of cannabis that they took out of did
they had there at their facility and
that's me on the far right and I'm
sampling one type and I know two helpers
that were sampling two other types and
the picture below the second picture
just shows that we just all we did was
just exposed the sqv field samplers to
the cannabis flowers for about five
minutes then we shipped the samplers
back to Milla pour Sigma in Bellefonte
Pennsylvania and about two weeks later i
desorbed them into a GCMs system this
was the first variety that we sampled
hippie Crippler the second variety
Slimer and the third variety which was
super Orange Crush and you can see we
got very nice européenne profiles and
we're able to see some differences
between them so this could be a pretty
useful tool if say you wanted to do some
terpene sampling for qualitative reasons
perhaps out in the fields for
identification of a strain or other
reasons
now quantitation of terpenes using us
Timmy we also worked up a quantitative
method and this method was they had some
different parameters than our
qualitative methods and we chose to look
at three specific terpenes that are of
interest pining limonene a little and we
studied them from the cannabis variety
that we had in house that we had
obtained from NIDA we spiked what we
found was when we did the qualitative
determination we then analyzed our
cannabis quantitatively and we found
that the candidate the terpene content
on it was very very very low okay we
don't know how old the cannabis was we
don't know what variety it was so in
order to make it closer to the varieties
that are being sold in dispensaries now
we had to spike the cannabis with known
levels of terpenes to bring it up to
relevant levels and that's what we did
so we spiked their cannabis and then
quantitated it against a curve that we
had prepared and extracted by SPME and
then we compare that to that spiked
cannabis sample that we prepared by a
conventional extraction method many labs
use an ethanol extraction which is what
I'm showing on this slide to produce an
extract that they just shoot into a GCF
ID to look for terpenes the extract is a
beautiful green color as you can see and
it also turns the GC liner a nice green
color after about 10 runs we found so
what we did was we took this spike to
extract we extracted it with with the
ethanol method I'm showing bail and we
also extracted it using our headspace
spme method and what we found was that
the results were very close to each
other
reproducibility was good for both
techniques and the accuracy was good for
both techniques the difference is is
that with SPME we did not have to use
any organic solvent it was also a
hands-off technique we set up the
samples and walked away there were
basically two steps just putting the
cannabis in the file
we found adding a little water helps
putting it up on the instrument walking
away where as you can see with the
ethanol extraction there's essentially
three to four steps that are required
and you still end up with a green
extract that kind of mucks up your
instrument
so why GCMs for terpenes here's another
thing - a lot of labs use fi d GCMs is
better why well if you use fi d you're
not going to be able to know for sure
what you're looking at is what you think
it is and what do I mean by that well
let's take a look at this peak at
nineteen point eight one minute set of
the terpene peak by GCMs nice peak if we
look at the spectrum on the back half of
it compared to the front there are some
similar ions but you can see that
they're very different the reason is is
these are two terpenes or co loading
with each other
looking at that peak you would never
know okay but if by looking at spectra
on the front versus the back you can
tell that they're two essentially two
things coming off together so what I did
was I subtracted the front the back from
the front and I was able to identify it
as this compound here that I'm showing
on the on the bottom left so GCMs helps
to identify for sure these Peaks as
specific terpenes now is spectral
searching like I just showed you a
sufficient by itself to identify terpene
not entirely for example let's say we
have two terpene Peaks one at twenty
five point eight five minutes and one
they've looked at twenty five point nine
seven minutes let's look at their
spectra this is my first peak at twenty
five point eight five minutes and it is
alpha yep a lang gene I think that's
pronounced now the second peak
is identified as a completely different
terpene yes they have very similar mass
spectra very similar almost the same so
if you tried to identify that those
Peaks by spectral searching you could
alone you could you could potentially
miss identify them so in this case it's
good to know the retention times that
you're looking for so that makes having
standards very important okay a
retention indices is a little more
complicated to use
that's a nice tool as well but the main
thing is a standard so if you're looking
for specific lists of terpenes you want
to have standards of known composition
so that you know the retention times of
those terpenes and also you want to be
able to make sure that you're not having
anything cold loading with the terpene
so using standards combined with
spectral identification you're going to
get correct results most of the time
so the last topic I'm going to talk
about is mycotoxin testing and this is
this is a realm of testing it's not
quite as common as the other things that
I've talked about but more and more
we're starting to see that that states
are requiring this I do believe that
California is going to require this now
mycotoxins are produced by fungi that
are naturally present on the cannabis
plants the thing is always at mycotoxins
are toxic to humans and some are
suspected of causing cancer so they're
analyzed by GC and HPLC mainly HPLC
after some type of extraction and
cleanup and mycotoxins are commonly
analyzing grain and a common cleanup for
this type of analysis involves something
called an immuno affinity column but
these columns have some issues
associated with them they're expensive
they have to be stored under
refrigeration there is another way
though to do to clean up and using solid
phase extraction and we have a cartridge
that's called s'appelle tox and there's
a series of them for doing mycotoxin
cleanup and so we tested one of these
cartridges out with a cannabis extract
to see how well it would clean it so we
extracted the canvas as if we were
looking for mica toxins it was a
beautiful green color as you can see
there
then after afterwards we spiked it with
mica toxins and we ran it through a
cleanup cartridge called the s'appelle
tox app Lizzie as a simple pass through
and then we looked at the recovery of
the mycotoxins and also looked at the
resulting extract to see how clean it
was so after passing it through the
cartridge you can see it went from this
emerald green color to a nice clear
maybe pale yellowish color so it's
fairly clean and there was no
precipitate in the final extract Ida
now as far as the mycotoxins we spiked
in this was the LC ms/ms analysis that
we did for recovery on those and the
recoveries were good so we didn't lose
them on the cleanup which is very
important so cleanup is is if you clean
something really well that's great but
if it takes away your analytes you
really can't use it so that that's
everything that I have for you today and
I want to thank you very much for your
attention and just let you know that
we're dedicated to making your life in
the lab successful so don't hesitate to
contact us if you have any any questions
or if you need help with with anything
that you're working on so thank you very
much and at this point I'll turn it over
back to you Kaylee
Thank You Kathy for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do
some map just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button well answer as many
questions as you have time for let's get
started our first question is I'm doing
catchers extraction on cannabis for
pesticide testing and use PSA c18 GCB
for the cleanup can I substitute the
very mix directly or do I have to change
my method actually you can just
substitute it directly you don't have to
do any other types of changes to your
method it was designed to be a direct
substitute it will offer the same
advantages of PSA c18 GCB so it will
remove these sugars it will take out
pigments it will take out fats the added
advantages we have a specially
engineered carbon in that mixture so
that it will not reduce the recoveries
of the plainer pesticides nearly as much
as GCB would so yes you can just
directly substitute it
alright and this next question is a
two-part question it says well other
tuned avenues besides THC covert the two
neutral form if analyzed by GC is there
any way to use GC and still distinguish
neutral and acidic THC from each other
other cannabinoids if they're acidic
they will also convert so yes you're
going to see them only as the neutral
forms if GC is all you have and you want
to try to distinguish the two forms one
approach and it's a it's a little more
complicated than HPLC is two derivatives
to sample so you would essentially be
derivatized the acidic group on the
acidic forms of the cannabinoids so that
you could get a distinct peak with a
separate retention time from the neutral
form there's there is some you know
there's some drawbacks organization it's
an extra step and whatnot and so a lot
of people shy away from it but you can
do it
all right and we have time for one more
question it says what equipment is
required to do SPM II
to do SPME to get started with it if all
you basically need is a holder like what
I showed in one of my slides I showed a
manual holder and a set of fibers that's
pretty much it and the vials most labs
already have that so if you just wanted
to try it you could just start with that
and it's it's also advantageous to have
a hot plate to warm the sample on so
those three things are enough to get
most people started and a ring stand -
there's accessories that are available
that it's especially to hold things that
make life a little easier and then
eventually if you find that you like the
technique and it's working for what you
want to do many labs will then convert
an automated system like what you saw in
my slides I have a an XYZ auto sampler
that has a head on to press P me and all
that equipments all readily available so
technically you don't have to do any
changes to your GC just to try it you
don't need a special than letter or
anything you just need to have a holder
and fibers
wonderful thank you again Kathy do you
have any final comments from our
audience I just want to thank the
audience again for for tuning in for the
webinar today and I look forward to
hopefully hearing from some of you
great and I would like to once again
thank copy sunderson for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29th 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay to share that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye